abrir para volver a cerrar en sólo
cuatro días este centro de vacunación en
un suburbio del centro de parís se quedó
sin vacunas así que todas las citas
pendientes tuvieron que suspenderse un
mes pero esperamos que no sonó fuerte
hasta junio un buen swap en otro centro
el demo a una hora al norte de parís se
repite la misma historia 200 citas
tuvieron que ser reprogramadas porque no
había vacunas pero tuvimos que parar
pronto porque no quedaban vacunas
por desgracia tuvimos que volver a mucha
gente que había venido y ahora tenemos
que cerrar este centro euro inicialmente
eso también este centro en antena tuvo
que cerrar todo por la tarde de manera
temporal hasta el gimnasio que había
sido reabierto como centro de vacunación
estaba listo para albergar a filas de
personas y ese todo a la vez
normalmente a esta hora debería haber
enfermeras vacunas
exide en aquellos centros todavía
abiertos como éste de mullus los
pacientes señalan que conseguir una cita
fue una odisea es un alivio haber
conseguido una cita eso seguro y el
stoke actual necesita ser reemplazado
ya quedan pocas existencias ahora mismo
tenemos lo suficiente para las próximas
dos semanas el plan del gobierno es
vacunar a 4 millones de personas para
finales de febrero